you
oh good morning I'm sorry to call so it
is it possible to speak to lars peter
hansen please oh hello my name is adam
smith i'm calling from nobelprize.org
the official website of the nobel prize
in stockholm sweden yeah we have a
tradition of interviewing new laureates
on the day of the announcement just for
two or three minutes would you be happy
to speak I would be thank you well first
of all many congratulations on the
economics prize thank you how did you
hear the news I just got a phone call I
about 10 minutes at 10 or 15 minutes ago
were you sleeping when it came I know um
I would early rise her so what I'd
already taken my dog out was eating
breakfast and was about to head off to
exercise and what was your first thought
I'm hearing it I great surprise I was ya
know III was of course very pleasantly
surprised but I was very surprised and
the price links you with Eugene fama and
Robert Shiller yeah that must be nice ah
sure yeah I've great respect for both
scholars and certainly been influenced
by their work as well and i feel quite
old I guess I'm the youngster in this
crew your work really deals with the
question of uncertainty and how you deal
with uncertainty and risk yeah yeah and
for those who are not in the finance
community and haven't really encountered
this before how would you describe what
you do um i think is kind of two aspects
to it one is I've done work on what
knows what's called at econometrics
order which is a statistic some
economics and and and I'd in I did work
that I think of in a very simple way is
trying to show you how you can do it
without having to do everything it's
kind of a funny way to put it but um if
you want to study and I namak economic
system what you'd like to do is focus on
the linkages say between asset markets
of the macro economy without having to
model everything at the same time
so that so my kind of metric worklist
kind of devoted towards that and that
opened the way to think about studying
and testing a variety of different asset
pricing models and models that link the
macro economy and security market so for
me it's in and then when certainly comes
into play as you need to have ways to
address the fact that investors say they
they respond to information and they
struggle with kind of you know what the
right mark you know what the right view
of the world is and you need to have
ways to kind of capture that you know
those struggles and how they reflect an
asset market hmm and how well do you
think we can do that now we're making a
little progress I think it's I think
there's a lot more to be done but I I
think that you're the challenges have
been remitted the modeling challenges
have been made clear and I think this
bent I think that opens the door for a
lot of exciting future work thank you
and you work at Chicago and there have
been so many economics prizes for the
University of Chicago what is it about
the place that is so productive yeah
it's interesting yeah I thought yeah I
for that I bet I bet if I quite a while
so I actually watched many of my
colleagues stuff in the past--get Nobel
prizes and I'm very close to some of
those um it's it's a few things I mean
certainly having such a distinguished
faculty said great example for me I mean
to have a lot of my colleagues where I
had been people with very broad interest
in economics not just narrow nearly
focused interest in and really convinced
that economics has zero explain stuff to
understand the real world better is not
such as from intellectual game and
completely committed to that type of
mentality and you know it's people here
just don't slow down I've got you I've
got senior colleagues like Jim Hackman
gary becker and Bob locusts but now they
just stay at the remain incredibly
active incident they remain incredibly
energetic and are impermeable remarkable
role model well I think it kind of
breaths and the fact that you really
want to take economics seriously and
that is and that's is there to do
something meaningful
thank you very much indeed now we would
if we may like to speak to you at a
greater length in a couple of weeks time
perhaps but for now we should leave you
to get on with what to looking like it's
going to be a pretty busy day to you
worry I don't quite know it what the
head for me but I'm sure you're right i
guess i guess i guess the world's press
are gonna descend on you how would you
feel about that how do you feel about
publicity i I haven't really processed
that part yet so I guess I'm gonna have
to wing it okay well best of luck with
it all and once again many
congratulations here thank you alright
bye